first on CBS mornings we're finally
hearing from convicted sex offender
Elaine Maxwell from her new prison in
Florida senior International interviewer
Daphne Barack spoke with Maxwell over
the phone back in August Maxwell you'll
recall was sentenced to 20 years in
prison for sexually abusing recruiting
and trafficking girls for convicted sex
offender Jeffrey Epstein's alleged sex
abuse ring her attorneys have already
appealed her conviction and the sentence
a rock conversation with Maxwell covered
a wide range of topics from conditions
inside the prison and how she's spending
her time to what she says she regrets
so what do you think you made any
mistake or just it's just a very bad
luck if you go back if you look back
where do you think you should have done
something different meeting acting was
the greatest mistake of my life and
obviously if I could go back today
um I would avoid meeting him
um and I would say that that would be
the greatest mistake I've ever made and
I would make different choices where I
would work obviously do you consider
yourself a victim of Epstein
um I I I am I don't particularly like
the word victim I think it's one that
should be used very sparingly because
you know today everybody is a victim of
something a victim of the pandemic a
victim of you know inflation I've heard
victim the word victim used about things
that I I don't like that word
so stay tuned to our Paramount plus
streaming app will soon have an
exclusive special on glean Maxwell you
want to miss that so that's sort of a
clip from what she's been saying to
Daphne from behind prison bars pretty
pretty broad there the biggest mistake
is meeting meetings I mean yeah there
are a couple of choices along the way
yeah right yeah I think for sure and
there are actual victims in yeah
and exactly right and then it's been
convicted for being the one who
facilitated that victim so